welcome back well Humana the sponsors of
this next segment are hosting two senior
Spring Fling events this week and here
to tell us more is Judith Fleischman and
Rachel Townsend thank you ladies so much
for being here thank you so let's talk
about you have two spring flings one
tomorrow one on the 20th what does that
entail what is the senior Spring Fling
well uh Spring Fling is an event where
our we're celebrating the welcoming up
spring for our seniors we're going to
have Refreshments we're going to have
live entertainment we're going to have
activities that are geared towards the
seniors and we're going to have a hat
contest that they're decorating right
now and they're making they're gonna
we're gonna have the best hat contest
and it's just going to be a wonderful
celebration from 9 30 to 11 30. first
location will be at 2335 East Lake Mead
in North Las Vegas and the second one on
the 20th will be at 3265 East traffic
Hannah and our Wellness Center from 9 30
to 11 30. that's incredible so is this
open to anyone and how do people get
involved with it well it's open uh yes
to our senior population but if anybody
wants to come by the purpose is to show
them our clinics and to show them all
the services that we have which are
Under One Roof but they can see they can
meet a provider they can have their lab
work done their x-ray
physiotherapy
sonograms wellness and we have benefit
coordinators and Social Services
coordinators to help them navigate some
of the difficulties that our seniors
sometimes face well these are really
important events it sounds like they'll
be fun too so a little bit of everything
Rachel bring you into the conversation
here do you touched on it a little bit
but just overall tell us a little bit
about Humana and what you guys do in the
community sure well Humana is a Medicare
Advantage company we are actually one of
the biggest companies in the United
States here locally in the valley we do
offer HMO and PPO plants that offer very
good benefits and low out-of-pocket
costs for our members we do work closely
with cono Health to serve the
community's health care needs and
they're one of our preferred providers
and they do have several locations
throughout the valley and in the East
South Nellis East Tropicana East Lake
Mead and I think to the West West
Charleston and to the north they've got
their Craig location and West Lake Mead
so we're super super happy to be working
with them and actually working with our
seniors out in the community yeah you
guys have the city covered every single
of it and just lastly here how important
is it for you to help those seniors in
our community they need the education
they need to know how to you know take
care of themselves best right they do
and they also need to be treated
correctly our seniors require you know
special care right and they really
appreciate it when you remember them and
when you can give them that from the
heart I remember you let's take care of
you that they need that the most our
senior population only keeps on growing
absolutely so we need to make sure that
these services are easy to navigate for
our seniors well ladies thank you so
much for everything you're doing and
again all that information was on your
screen two spring flings happening this
weekend for or this week for more
information can call Kano Health at
702-848-2875
we'll be right back
[Music]